when I'm described as lgbtq I say how
dare you first of all how can I be all
those things at once I don't have the
time secondly how dare you call me
anything other than my own definition of
myself which is first and foremost a
human being and a lesbian
imagine if Kathleen stock and I decided
to take a little trip down to the pride
March we would be absolutely vilified we
would probably be attacked we'd be
surrounded and we are two lesbians who
have fought for lesbian Liberation and
who believe in the rights of women and
all human beings to exist without
discrimination but we would be under
attack and it would be worse Julie all
of this would be done to you by the
people saying Love Is Love that's right
love will love wins love wins especially
when you're beating up lesbians
apparently